[Música]
eeuu aún no tiene el presidente electo
el candidato demócrata joe biden le
lleva la delantera al republicano donald
trump en estados clave como pensilvania
que tiene la llave de la victoria
el escrutinio en seis estados tiene a
eeuu en vino en medio de protestas y en
un ambiente de máxima atención
alaska arizona nevada pensilvania
georgia y carolina del norte avanzan en
los conteos mientras donald trump
continúa su batalla legal y denuncia sin
pruebas un supuesto fraude electoral
varios países europeos están confinados
ante la segunda ola de la pandemia que
deja cerca de 12 millones de contagios y
casi 300.000 muertos en el continente en
francia se registraron más de 60.000
nuevos casos en las últimas 24 horas
[Música]
hola cómo están buenas noches en américa
latina y a todos ustedes que nos siguen
por la señal de france 24 mi nombre es
alan austria y hoy que es viernes sean
bienvenidos el 6 de noviembre y eeuu
continúa en vilo después de la elección
presidencial mientras sigue el conteo en
seis estados donald trump insiste en
cuestionar la integridad del sistema
electoral del país al poner en
entredicho y sin pruebas la legalidad de
millones de votos el presidente sigue
presentando demandas contra el
escrutinio y dijo que buy the no debería
declararse como ganador hasta tener el
resultado de sus demandas por su parte
el candidato demócrata se aproxima a
obtener suficientes votos para ganar la
presidencia y se espera que dé un
discurso en cualquier momento las
movilizaciones continúan de parte de
seguidores de ambos candidatos los de
trump se congregaron este viernes en
phoenix arizona para protestar por lo
que consideran un proceso corrupto
veamos cómo está el mapa electoral de la
agencia de noticias estadounidense ap la
fuente del conteo para france 24 que ya
le otorga a arizona a biden ya que según
explicó analizó las papeletas restantes
y concluyó que el presidente trump ya no
podría alcanzar a byd en allí según
'associated press' joe biden acumula 264
votos electorales y está a 6 de los 270
necesarios para ganar mientras que trump
acumula a 214 la cadena conservadora fox
news también atribuyó a arizona a baile
sin embargo otros medios de comunicación
estadounidenses como la cadena cnn y el
diario 'new york times' aún no le
otorgan el estado de arizona a bailén
por lo que sin esos 11 votos electorales
del estado de arizona los resultados
estarían así yo bailé en 253 y donald
trump 214
son 6 los estados que tienen a eeuu en
vilo estos son los últimos datos de un
conteo que tiene que definir al
presidente estadounidense como les
decíamos adicionada porta 11 votos
electorales con el 94 por ciento
escrutado joe biden tiene 49.9 por
ciento
donald trump 48 puntos 6 votos por
contar 235 mil cuando se sabrá los
resultados el conteo seguirá durante
todo el día y se esperan más datos en el
transcurso de la noche
pensilvania con 20 votos electorales ha
escrutado hasta el momento el 98 por
ciento de sus papeletas
allí lidera joe biden con un 49.5 por
ciento frente a un muy cercano 49.3 por
ciento del presidente de donald trump y
aún quedan unos 120.000 votos por
escrutar la mayoría de ellos en zonas
urbanas las autoridades estatales
esperan terminar el escrutinio este
viernes aunque los resultados
electorales en filadelfia según los
responsables dicen que aún podrían
tardar días pues la corte suprema ordenó
separar las papeletas recibidas después
del día de la elección
y vamos a seguir contando las papeletas
lo más rápido que podamos sin sacrificar
la precisión como lo hemos hecho desde
el principio cuando me quieren dar ahí
es donde están terminaremos cuando
termine un amiguete van carolina delorte
aporta 15 votos electorales y con un 99
por ciento escrutado trump tiene ahí 50%
y bailén también muy cercano 48.6 por
ciento votos por contar 116 mil carolina
del norte acepta hasta el 12 de
noviembre de las papeletas enviadas por
correo postal
en alaska que otorga tres votos
electorales solo se ha escrutado el 50%
de los votos
donald trump lidera en este estado con
62 puntos 9% frente al 33% de joe biden
ningún voto por correo o ausente será
contado hasta cerca de una semana
después del 3 de noviembre
y en georgia la carrera está muy
ajustada con el 99 por ciento de los
votos escrutados joe biden tiene 49.4
por ciento y también donald trump que
tiene el mismo porcentaje
faltan por contar 16 mil votos el
secretario de estado de georgia ha
estado con 16 delegados en el colegio
electoral ha anunciado que dado lo
ceñido de este escrutinio se procederá a
un recuento por lo que los resultados
definitivos podrían tardar varios días
los votantes de georgia merecen
resultados electorales precisos y reales
los trabajadores electorales en todo el
estado están trabajando con integridad
para garantizar que se cuenten todas las
boletas legales y que no se cuenten las
bolitas ilegales
en este momento la diferencia en georgia
es muy pequeña para dar un resultado en
evaluar con 6 votos electorales las
autoridades reportaron el escrutinio del
87 por ciento de los votos también
lidera gi joe biden con 49 puntos 7%
seguido de trump con 40 y 8.1 por ciento
aunque todavía quedan unas 63.000
papeletas por contar se espera que el
resultado final se sepa antes del
domingo nevadas siga aceptando sufragios
por correo hasta el martes de la semana
que viene el 90% de los votos restantes
son del condado de las vegas donde los
demócratas son mayoría
a partir de hoy comenzaremos a informar
nuestros resultados dos veces al día
así que ya hemos visto la actualización
de esta mañana y por la tarde
publicaremos un informe de prensa sobre
las boletas por correo que se han
agregado al sistema en algún momento
antes de las 4 en punto
y en este mismo estado los ciudadanos de
nevada van a tener que presentar una
identificación o un documento de
identidad para confirmar su voto nos
explica por qué nuestra enviada especial
susana mentos a docenas de personas
llevan horas haciendo fila cada vez van
llegando más y son personas
bueno pues confusas o enfadadas porque
no entienden qué es lo que ha pasado con
su voto la mayor parte de las personas
que esperan aquí han recibido
notificaciones o emails diciendo que su
voto no es válido y que tienen que venir
aquí al condado de clark a el
departamento de elecciones para
verificar su identidad o para verificar
que efectivamente ellos han ejercido su
derecho al voto bueno estoy aquí porque
quiero que mi voto cuente para el
presidente trump quiero hacer la
diferencia
por eso estoy aquí bueno fuimos a votar
hace como tres semanas un mes y nos
dijeron que está todo bien los
documentos todo listo y nos llamaron
ayer y hoy diciendo que algo estaba mal
con la identificación entonces que
estamos esperando para arreglar todo
porque todas las otras cuentan de
ciertamente ha creado mucha ansia como
si necesitáramos más verbal que
estábamos además de la disputa por la
presidencia estadounidense demócratas y
republicanos aún sostienen una batalla
por el control del senado y de la cámara
de representantes según los resultados
aún parciales
el partido demócrata mantendrá el
control de la cámara y los republicanos
están en una fuerte carrera por mantener
el control del senado entidades que son
estratégicas para la gobernabilidad del
próximo mandatario así aunque el duelo
entre yobái de nito naciente está
absorbiendo toda la atención no es sólo
la presidencia la que está en juego en
eeuu los votantes también designan a
otros miles de cargos desde senadores
hasta sheriff y legisladores locales en
cuanto a los 435 escaños
de la cámara de representantes los
resultados parciales sugieren una
ventaja para los demócratas se
presentaron a las elecciones de esta
semana con grandes esperanzas de
aumentar su control mayoritario de la
cámara pero el partido sufre hasta el
momento la pérdida de cerca de seis
escaños
además distritos como iowa incluso una
parte de california que los demócratas
habían recuperado en 2018 no
permanecieron azules miren a wayne pero
no ganamos todas las batallas pero
ganamos la guerra los estadounidenses
también fueron llamados el martes para
renovar un tercio del senado por una
parte los republicanos conquistaron
estados clave pero no han conseguido los
escaños necesarios para declarar que
ostentan la mayoría las esperanzas
demócratas ahora descansan en georgia
este estado podría en efecto definir la
inclinación del senado pero la carrera
parece encaminarse a una segunda vuelta
espero que el resultado de las
elecciones sea positivo porque todos nos
llevamos bien realmente ambos partidos
se llevan bien espero realmente espero
que los asientos en el senado sigan
siendo los mismos para que puedan
aprender a llevarse bien
y los estadounidenses tendrán que ser
pacientes para saber los resultados
finales ya que ante este contexto en
algunos casos no se resolverá sino hasta
el próximo año y ahora el riesgo es que
el próximo presidente se quede sin una
mayoría clara en el senado y la cámara
el avance del coronavirus paraliza
ciudades y regiones del continente
europeo que supera ya los 12 millones de
contagios y registra casi 300.000
muertes y además aumenta ahora la
incertidumbre ante el inesperado foco en
dinamarca de una mutación del virus
detectada en humanos francia tuvo récord
de casos con 60 mil 400 y más de 800
fallecimientos italia también tuvo
récord con casi 38 mil positivos
europa sigue siendo el foco de atención
del planeta covite la mutación del virus
ocurrida en una población de visones en
dinamarca ha sido también detectada en
214 personas que trabajan en granjas me
gustaría recordarles que las mutaciones
son normales este tipo de cambios en el
virus es algo que hemos estado
rastreando desde el principio y el reino
unido tiene el mayor número de muertes
por cop 19 en europa en consecuencia a
gran bretaña lanzó un plan piloto de
pruebas masivas en la ciudad de
liverpool este viernes ofreciendo a
todos pruebas tengan unos síntomas así
creo personalmente que cualquier cosa
que nos devuelva a una vida normal es
algo bueno realmente en mi opinión no
dependiendo no estoy diciendo que no lo
haría obviamente me gustaría saber un
poco más al respecto pero si nos ayuda a
volver a una vida normal entonces estoy
feliz por algo así de verdad el programa
es un intento del gobierno británico de
encontrar una nueva forma de utilizar
las pruebas para limitar la propagación
del coronavirus mientras el país conoce
su segundo cierre nacional
de este jueves también desde el jueves
italia experimentó toques de queda de
las 10 de la noche a las 5 de la mañana
y desde hoy italia está dividida en tres
con regiones amarillas naranjas y rojas
según los indicadores de peligrosidad
que maneja el gobierno y que han
desatado críticas creo que poner algunas
regiones en la zona roja y excluir otras
no es una solución
mucha gente lo ve como una decisión
injusta y de hecho es un poco injusta si
decides que el bloqueo debe aplicarse a
todos en cualquier caso no hemos
aprendido nada de la experiencia que
tuvimos en marzo y que está marzo está
bueno que habíamos visto tomar son o
bien para mí para teniente o italia
superó 40.000 muertos y es el segundo
país después del reino unido
la depresión tropical letra sigue
provocando estragos en centroamérica
este viernes el presidente de guatemala
anunció que la tormenta dejó al menos
150 personas muertas también azotó zonas
en honduras dejando miles de
damnificados
la fuerza de eta arrasó con las casas de
miles de personas en guatemala que
quedaron atrapadas en los techos y
tuvieron que ser evacuadas en
helicópteros las operaciones de rescate
no han sido fáciles por la destrucción
de algunas carreteras además la
depresión tropical ha afectado a por lo
menos 75.000 personas en el país
centroamericano van a prevalecer las
lluvias hasta va hasta la mañana del
sábado todas nos quedarían 36 48 horas
de lluvia y después de eso nos va a
quedar un terreno muy alegado con una
sobrecarga de agua muy importante y
vamos a tener tener mucho cuidado con
los deslaves los derrumbes en las
carreteras y sobre todo en el tema de
los puentes que aunque están siendo
golpeados el centro nacional de
huracanes de eeuu advirtió que las
inundaciones continuarán en la región
en honduras ésta ha provocado grandes
inundaciones y deslizamientos de tierra
si me duele mucho
tenía mi casita es tu juguete acabe la
calle
es triste para mí
mucho mejor y nicaragua decenas de casas
fueron arrasadas y los propios
habitantes han tenido que limpiar los
escombros por falta de ayuda de las
autoridades la tormenta tocó tierra el
pasado martes en nicaragua como un
potente huracán de categoría 4 y fue
debilitándose progresivamente el
archipiélago colombiano de san andrés
providencia y santa catalina también fue
castigado por el poder de la tormenta
las autoridades declararon la zona bajo
calamidad pública los pronósticos del
centro nacional de huracanes de eeuu
indican que la depresión tropical
regresará al mar y recuperará impulso
como tormenta y posiblemente pasará por
las islas cayman cuba y el sur de
florida en los próximos días muchas
gracias y ya con nosotros en france 24
[Música]